hi I'm
I'm here to present on the subject of
lip-reading with AI something called
assistive augmentation so let's first
get started quickly introducing myself
I'm a graduate student at Illinois Tech
anybody from Chicago in the house show
of hands
cool I'm a data scientist at foreign
labs it's a 3d printing manufacturer
anybody it's why around with 3d printing
here awesome awesome
yeah and actually for over ten years I
was a web developer and the webmaster
and managed three you know web projects
any web developers here yeah I thought
so I forgot to ask but can you hear me
well everybody cool okay
I asked what if you couldn't hear me at
all
you know what if it was hard for you to
hear even a close proximity it's
actually a more common problem that you
would think there's actually something
called you know the Americans with
Disability Act has been it was passed in
1990 and you know it prohibits
discrimination based you know it it
makes sure that there's reasonable
accommodation for all persons with
disability despite of it there are many
areas in which there aren't reasonable
accommodations you know live speaking
events like this one but there is you
know but sometimes you know quite often
it's not the case
you know conferences meetups lessons
lectures you got to think what if in
your you're like at a train station or
Airport you know and you know there's a
public announcement how can you tell if
you can't hear you know usually there's
there speak
for that there's a PA system or a GA
system and and theatrical events they
lack captioning at all for the most part
unless a forum film so there's a lot of
cases in which reasonable accommodations
for the deaf and hard of hearing aren't
covered at least proactively and even if
they were covered there's a lot of
common issues that you know deaf and
hard-of-hearing people have you know
they they have simply daily interactions
cause you know like that they have to
have some kind of verbal response
unexpectedly you know like say they're
at the supermarket and you know the the
cashier tells them something they have
no idea what they said so the core issue
it's it's an invisible disability
there's ten million people that have
some form of from moderate to complete
profile a hearing profound hearing loss
and this is three times as many people
that have died conic disability which is
you know having a wheelchair or a cane
and since it's not immediately apparent
you know this causes you know a lot of
lack of awareness misconceptions and the
policies and regulations surrounding it
you know don't don't cover a lot of
things don't make sure that they're
there they're there exist a reasonable
accommodation and reasonable
interactions with people with this sort
of disability in addition to a lack of
visibility there's a number of
misconceptions and some of them is that
all deaf people sign and this is very
wrong they they all read lips which is
very very difficult in fact you know
even professionals only are able to
detect up to 15 percent of what is said
through that method and
you know that hearing aids fix deafness
that they're the equivalent of
eyeglasses and they're not so let's talk
about solutions how to solve the
previously mentioned problems with
assistive technologies and let's examine
what I mean by assistive technologies so
these are assistive technologies you
might have seen before a Braille reader
for the blind a caption telephone for
the Deaf and a mouse stick for the
quadriplegic they're very helpful
they're very useful but they also have
their limitations
assistive augmentation on the other hand
a goes a step further and trying to help
people you know work around their
challenges and allow for seamless and
enhanced interaction and some of them
like the finger reader you just pointed
something and it reads it to you on
augmented reality headset which allows
anybody that doesn't have superhuman
motor skills do very very precise things
like for instance a surgeon you know
know exactly the distance between two
points or you know something of that to
that effect the you know also there's a
chewable pointer for a quadriplegic
person to actually you know be able to
point to something where their mouth
without having to use of a mouse stick a
lot of these things can help able-bodied
people as well
so like that's that's the sense of it
you know you like for instances even
exoskeletons that could help enable
pause bodied person you know with very
little elf effort you know pick up
things etc so and that could help
someone disabled as well so assistive
augmentation is about enhancement and
seamless enhancement and there's a
number of old-school solutions for the
deaf and hard-of-hearing
there's speech recognition which lacks
immersion
and doesn't work in noisy environments
their video relay services which relies
on other humans to interpret an
interface and there's closed captioning
for services which of course I I had
written this before I came to this
conference I mentioned I was referring
to automated closed captioning searches
because it live it's not usually sloppy
and tone-deaf so I apologize for that
I'm sure she's doing a fantastic job so
recent improvements and technologies and
their costs you know have a lot going
down have allowed for even better
technologies assistive Arman tation
solutions and for instance we have smart
caption glasses here that allows people
to seamless follow the performance in a
theatrical event in London we have a
special hardness for the deaf to feel
music during a concert which is also
very helpful to be able to engage that
kind of environment and then there's an
assisted listening system which it which
allows for a person to you know with
moderate hearing loss to actually enjoy
an event when they're farther away and
this is no this is not even a high tech
solution but you know given that there's
a lot of the people that have moderate
hearing loss are elderly you know that's
what's made this issue more visible and
allowed for things like this so a steam
collaborator a collaborator and I from
school we we start we we set out to
attempt to solve this problem using our
own tool set which is machine learning
but knowing what we knew about the end
user after all this research it was you
know we figured we we had to come up
with an assistive AG mentation solution
so that it comprehensively solved it
so say if he wanted to help a deaf or
hard-of-hearing person understand this
presentation without you know and say it
was a spontaneous and there wasn't a
closed caption er what would we have to
do we would have to come up with
something accessible that was
inexpensive and easy to use immersive so
it didn't distract too much from the
understanding enjoyment and and also
contextual empowered verbal and by that
I mean it was easy to identify the
context to a certain degree and also it
also included some para bearable
elements and I'll get into more of that
later but these are just basics and then
accurate and noise invariant and noise
wouldn't affect it like say if there was
a spontaneous laughter and I was still
talking they would be able to still
understand what I was saying so like we
we came up with you know drew up
something that would be like the ideal
solution and this is what we thought you
know you know just pull up a phone or a
tablet pointed at the speaker of course
be close enough for that to actually
work and and then it's it's immersive
because you just pointed it and able to
see the text underneath it's accessible
because it's a phone or a tablet and
they're reasonably cheap and it's not a
special device they have to get just for
that and you know and and also it has
power available components and by that I
mean like if I say this is exciting and
I say with a certain tone you can tell
you know by the green of course a
language has to be developed to actually
do that effectively and there is nothing
like that necessarily that you have in
written text the way of doing it other
than putting parentheses underneath or
or something to that effect lastly
there's the topic of accuracy noise and
variance
for that I'm gonna have to speak about
machine learning but I'll save that for
later okay
so how many of you have trained a
machine learning model okay reasonable
amount so I this is for the rest of them
the rest of us or none of us but of you
that haven't like I tied all this talk
about artificial intelligence because
you know more glitzy term
I personally don't prefer it but I
figured well if I put ml or machine
learning less people would come you know
so reality the thing is I this this
solution had to be deep learning and I'm
gonna get into it a bit a bit more but
machine learning is not more complicated
than you would expect basically you just
try to take a set of data feed it to a
model which then learns from it but it
learns only specifically from that data
you fed so it's not it doesn't it
doesn't necessarily have that capacity
inherently to to learn from anything
else other than what you gave it so
let's let's look at an example this is
the training process it's obviously an
oversimplification but you know you just
pour data into a big pile of linear
algebra and if the answers are wrong you
just stare stir it again and again until
you get right answers and so I chose
deep learning because deep learning can
do something a little bit more complex
let's say you have an image of you you
have a dog called Sparky and you want it
to be able to tell if it's if it's dog
obviously you know it's a dog but you
want to be able to take a picture and
say okay it's a dog so you you take a
collection of pictures of dogs versus
other things and you you put it into a
network so
the network what it does through the
magic of linear algebra it just starts
to identify different features from that
dog layer after layer after layer ever
every layer more complex than another so
first it might detect certain you know
edges then it might detect you know you
know collection of edges and then bigger
features you know knows you know ears
etc so then when it combines those
features in the last layer combines
those features together to identify oh
it's a dog and and to be clear it
doesn't you know it never tells you you
know shouldn't a hundred percent
accuracy it's a dog I'll tell you like
oh 0.85 percent accuracy it's a dog so
you know you kind of round it up in
comparison to all the other ones to
determine that it is indeed a dog so now
going back to the topic of lip ringing
why do lip reading at all and in other
words what does it have to do with
speech recognition well when I say
speech recognition recognition you might
imagine you know basically you just need
a microphone just like you just need an
ear to understand what I'm saying but if
we put it in the context of human
physiology we realize that you know
speech is not really you know sensory
there's a lot of instances in which
another sense you know enhances your
ability to understand and so that's
that's one of the things that is kind of
missing you know when you you pull out
your phone and you you point it it's
something that's being said and you say
okay just tell me what it's being said
you're really using one sense so ideally
a solution would combine more than one
sense so that it becomes really robust
so the the audio component can age the
visual and vice versa
so remember what I said about accuracy
and noise and variance so say you have a
video where you have a stream of you
know frames and in those frames you have
the movement of the mouse on the other
hand you have the audio basically
representing what's being said by that
mouth combining both you can achieve
greater accuracy in noise and variance
simply by the the this by the
possibility of what I'm going to tell
you next
okay so lip-reading and speech
recognition alike have a number of
challenges they're difficult because of
home affines and home phones and so this
is this is only becomes better humans
can understand these things because of
context and only because of context so
like in in English we have all these
instances and so is so the exists in
other languages which words sound very
alike and we can only understand them
you know because of the context of them
and this happens visually and also
auditorially so we could hear MIDI and
meteor and you know MIDI reader and
mediator and if these things were said
very quickly or with a different accent
it became really hard to understand so
for instance if the phrase was Michael
colored the bedroom wall with crayons an
example of homophone would be michael
colored the bedroom well with crayons
and the only reason we know it's not my
call it's Michael is context or maybe
because it was said you know very
clearly and slowly and and and in such a
way where you understood it's not
Michael it's Michael so the an example
of home afine is michael colored the
bedroom called with crayons because if
you said these that phrase call and well
with would shape the same mouth movement
so how to solve this with deep learning
we use something called long short-term
memory and this is what can take an
account the context so basically you
chain the networks together in such a
way where time is taking an account so
each network is a different time step
and it's learning and progression so
it's at same time learning from the
previous time steps it's also forgetting
and that's why it's called long
short-term memory so it it has a special
property it makes it easier to learn
long-term features because of that so
not a single as Ellis TM network is used
for this solution you have a listen
module of watch module which are
explained but you also have a spell
module and that's really important I
will I will explain that in a little bit
more detail later but the spell module
helps decode everything into a final
prediction so it takes it takes what's
coming out of each one and it's allowing
for it to discard any information that
isn't useful using their probabilities
and so this allows to figure out which
parts is - which parts to focus and
which ones to not so how many of you
have ever watched a TED almost everybody
so like TED Talks they're very diverse
they're very clear you know they're
reasonably well lit yet occasionally
obfuscated there's a very diverse set of
faces genders and ethnicities facial
hair etc and it's occasionally noisy
because of the clapping and
you know the laughing but you know like
there's also a diverse set of voices you
have different accents tones etc so like
what we did was take a collection of
these 500 hours of tech talks of which
400 were used for the training and was
extracted from YouTube and this was used
for the training so but the data set by
itself is really important to prepare it
well so that you know you make sure that
it's it's grabbing the right features
you're using the right parts of the data
when I when I said you know this
terrifying looking man is saying always
with the smile so when I said like you
you had to learn from different features
and you had to learn from the lips it's
important to isolate the lips for the
training so what we did here was take
the video and identify the mouth and
separate it and you know crop it up put
it into a Yuma uniform way so that it
was always centered on the mouth always
the same amount of you know pixels and
everything and at the same token we took
the audio and we separated and make sure
it matched so there's always with the
smile video you you have the you have
the the clip the the set of frames and
you have the audio and at the same time
you have also another hand what it's
supposed to say so it's it's going to
learn from the combination of these two
things against this predict this
prediction this this annotation
so the watch module the way it works is
that you you feed every time step you
know five frames at a time into
different LS diems in that are all
chained together and so but before you
even do that you have to use what I told
you about the you know remember what I
said about the dog about how to identify
if it's a dog or cat basically it's the
same architecture in the beginning so
you're you're trying to identify the
features of the face well not of a face
but a mouth region in the same manner so
it's going through a combo what's called
a convolutional neural network so the
the convolutional neural network is
pretty much the same thing I was talking
about with with the dog in this case so
your your each one of these is receiving
a CNN before it's going into the ostium
so that way you're not sending it an
entire you know range of images but
what's getting is a simplified version
of it just a bunch of features for each
sequence and what it's really learning
is from that sequence in the listen
module it's it doesn't have to do that
because audio is far more simple than
video so it's it's less complex in
nature it has less dimensions so and
there's already like there are already
algorithms to actually take audio and
put it take extract the essence of that
audio and one of those algorithms is
it's called the MCM FCC the mell
frequency sub sub string coefficients
and so you just take any audio clip and
you can run that and it will extract the
number of features that you need and so
I'm taking an equivalent amount of times
the same amount of
time and taking small clips like say for
every frame every set of frames I'm
sending to the to the watch module I'm
doing the same with the listen module
but I'm sending like just eat the the
equivalent clip but in audio so lastly
this goes this this goes into L STM
transducer which is which looks like
this and it has it first goes through
these and then in what is called an
attention module so that tension module
is really important because that's what
ultimately determines what what feature
is identified and is then processed you
know as into the output of the
predictions so the spell module is what
what takes everything that came before
it in the different time steps and
identifies what to discard or not okay
so this project was inspired by a Google
and deep mind deep mind is a lab in the
UK they've been very successful in and
in deep learning and a few years ago
they took footage from the BBC and did
something like this but solely on on
lips and it was quite a feat because you
know remember that I said people that
even professionals only achieve and here
it says 12.4% accuracy and they have
achieved nearly four times as much so
that was really really good our training
results were better than that but they
weren't near you know what you expect in
the industry and that's you know because
the data set was relatively small it
turns out 405 yeah 400 hours is not
enough
you know to actually train someone to
understand an entire language so yeah
but it's it's robust when compared to
lip-reading alone so let's see an
example of this you know this is I did a
Python implementation of you know what
ideally I would want on a phone so you
know you just point the camera and unto
you and you just start talking and it
uses both the an isolation of the mouth
region plus the sound to understand what
you're saying so here here I say can you
read my lips
obviously the if this were a transcript
done by a professional closed caption er
it would say can you read my lips
question mark it would understand by the
intonation in the context that it was a
question and obviously it doesn't do
this and then I I guess I got really
excited and nice and I spoke too quickly
but I thought I said oh wow it does work
but it says or wow does works I yeah I
got ahead of myself so so then to gain
insights to take this project and
understand exactly what to do next it's
really important to rely on the on the
test data set so we we had holdout of
you know I think about a hundred hours
worth of test data set so we could tell
if it was actually you know working in
in unseen data by the model and so let's
see a few clips in fact in our data grit
is usually unrelated or even inversely
related to measures of talent see so
sometimes it works perfectly but the
the differences the speaker here is
talking slowly with clear intonation
snow slang
very common accents words that are
particularly difficult and the lips are
easy to locate as you can tell I have it
that isolated however in this one this
is actually a combination of three clips
that were previously unseen so I knew I
was dealing with a professional the word
should be about 2.5 million this is the
first time I share billion and my friend
knew it
so this was particularly challenging see
there's there's an accent it there's
there's different kinds of speed and the
cadence is is off it's in particularly
last one you know what it predicted is
completely off you know instead of no no
no at the end it's not new new new which
is not even close so and sometimes the
problem is with the unknown words
sometimes as with people you you have to
hear a word not even only once you have
to hear it many times before you can
understand it in context and this is an
example of that efficiency works really
well when you can predict exactly what
you're going to need but when the
anomalous or unexpected comes up so here
it took anomalous and turned it into
normal Mouse I don't understand why I
would do that but like it just simply
there weren't enough examples with the
word anomalous for it to understand it
so even though it was it was in the
training set in other places it just it
it thought Mouse was more probable
nope I didn't build that company I
didn't even start I was actually a
marketing manager for a fortune 500
company so this one puzzled me quite a
bit because I was like okay well fortune
he's saying it clearly it's something
that said and a number of times in other
clips in similar context but for some
reason maybe maybe because it's close to
another number it's not for ton company
500 company would made more sense you
know
I asked myself three things one did you
mean it - can you defend it
so here the prediction error you know if
if I look at this I think oh it's okay
it's doing all right obviously it's it's
counting them as incorrect but you know
like lacking the parentheses or some
kind of punctuation to make sure you
know it's a I'm a numerating things is
something more complex than this model
was trained to do so and again the
question mark lacking a question mark is
that important is it not like obviously
if you were to try to make this
something reliable for assistive
augmentation you have to tackle these
problems but reality is it takes for a
much more complex model to actually do
with these things and a much larger
training set so if any any of you have
access to thousands of hours of training
data you know video annotated video
please let me know I'd be very
interested so thank you very much you
have any questions I'm available you can
reach me through these methods you know
email or Twitter or LinkedIn or can ask
me now
[Applause]
yeahthere's yeah that was done there's a
there's a machine learning model that
you can apply and it's you can find it
it's it's based on some research from a
Swedish Institute it's called Kazemi
sullivan and and it's it's very quick at
locating facial points so you can use it
to locate points in any picture once you
isolate the face it will find the points
and using those points you can identify
the lips and then what I did there was
just I ran it in a Python notebook it's
not that complex you just you to pidor
notebook I mean you just look for those
points using that model and then you
establish a margin and you just crop
around that margin and then if if say I
want it has to be a box so you just make
sure it's it's it's equal dimension and
then you just expand it to meet whatever
size you need in this case it's like 120
times 120 pixels so that's what I used
any questions
yeah that's a very good question he
asked if if I'm trying to add
punctuation and indeed I am I purposely
removed points final points from the
sentence because that's already in the
model by different token but like things
like comma like three points so special
points and and question marks were
tokenized in the hopes that it would
find them but it seldomly did because
it's it's it's very usually there isn't
like a sound or a movement of lips that
actually tells the model that's a
question it's learned by context and
often it's a context that needs you know
longer time stamps then the model has
been trained to to include like for
instance if if all I'm all I'm doing in
those time stamps is like a few seconds
worth of words you know and a sentence
is longer than that it's not it's not
gonna learn from that so that's that's a
problem yes
oh the the inference is is reasonably
quick I would say it's not super quick
but it's uh it might take like it
there's a lag time you can't see it by
the video but there's a lag time because
it's probably like I half a second yeah
but the the training itself took many
days yes
oh okay well ideally as as you've seen
like cameras like they're they're
becoming more and more megapixels and
there'll be a time and were we talking
about 40 50
I don't know 100 megapixels you know so
a lot of things are getting there
obviously if you're that far you
probably be able to get the sound but
the the the movement of the lips will be
less discernible at that range but if
you were like in the first few rows it'd
be a lot better using the current
technology but in a few years that could
change in just a couple of years the
same goes for inference on the phone
right now if I try to to run my my
Python script on a phone it wouldn't it
wouldn't be as you know it would be
significant lag time and it might even
crash yes that would be ideal because
you know say a person goes underground
you know to some kind of meet up you
know in a basement somewhere you know
it's they're going to be connection
issues and even with 5g you know the
fact that you have to be tethered for
something like that is is a problem Oh
[Music]
yeah yeah no I I think yeah what you're
saying is obviously like models need to
be updated so like just having a model
running on your on your phone and never
connecting is not a good idea either at
some point it has to connect and but
ideally there's like a hybrid solution
where you're like for things like this
like because of the possibilities of be
able to have inference on your phone in
real time you wouldn't wanna you know
you wouldn't want to restrict it with
that you know say there was an emergency
and they had to understand what a
paramedic was saying yeah sure okay sure
all right
[Applause]